דיאגונליזציה קוונטית של Krylov או בקיצור KQD מתייחסת לפתרון בעיית ערך מטריצה
על ידי הטלת המטריצה לתת-מרחב שמוכן על מחשב קוונטי בהתאם לשיטת Krylov, גישה
חזקה מאלגברה לינארית קלאסית. לאורך הסרטון הזה נחקור למה שיטת Krylov שימושית
ואיך ומתי ליישם אותה על מחשבים קוונטיים.
אז מה זה שיטת Krylov? נניח שיש לנו מטריצה H שקשורה למאמץ מדעי או עסקי עם n שורות ו-n
עמודות. אנחנו מעוניינים בערך העצמי הנמוך ביותר e0 ובוקטור העצמי המתאים psi 0. בואו נגדיר
וקטור התחלתי v שיכול להיות מונע מהמבנה של h או שיכול להיות אקראי לחלוטין. תת-מרחב Krylov
מסדר r שאנחנו כותבים k r נוצר על ידי הפעלת h על הוקטור
ההתחלתי הזה r פחות אחת פעמים תוך הוספת התוצאה של כל הפעלת h עוקבת
לקבוצת וקטורי הפריסה כלומר kr הוא המרחב הנפרס על ידי הוקטורים v
hv h בריבוע וכן הלאה. הוקטורים האלה לא יהיו בדרך כלל אורתוגונליים.
באופן קלאסי, אנחנו לרוב מבצעים תהליך אורתוגונליזציה מאוד דומה לתהליך גרם-שמידט. מתחילים
בנרמול הוקטור ההתחלתי V וקוראים לתוצאה V0. אז לוקטור הבא HV, מחסירים את
ההטלה שלו על V0 כדי להפוך את שני הוקטורים לאורתוגונליים. אז מנרמלים את התוצאה. ממשיכים ככה,
מפעילים שוב את H והופכים את התוצאה לאורתוגונלית לכל הוקטורים שנוספו קודם עד שבונים R
וקטורים אורתונורמליים הנדרשים לפרוס את תת-מרחב Krylov ה-R-ממדי שלכם.
ברגע שיש לכם את תת-המרחב הזה, מטילים את המטריצה עליו ומלכסנים את המטריצה המוטלת הקטנה יותר. יש
עדינויות והרחבות, אבל זו שיטת Krylov ברמה הפשוטה ביותר שלה.
כדי לקבל תחושה טובה יותר של איך זה עובד, בואו נסתכל על דוגמה טריוויאלית. אם H היא המטריצה הזו ו-V נבחר להיות הוקטור
הזה, אז נתחיל בנרמול V. כדי ליצור את הוקטור השני בתת-מרחב Krylov, מפעילים
פעם אחת את H על הוקטור ההתחלתי שלנו ואז הופכים את התוצאה לאורתוגונלית ל-V0.
קצת אלגברה נותנת את זה עבור V1.
זה לא שימושי למטריצות כל כך קטנות ובדרך כלל לא היינו עוצרים בממד Krylov של שתיים. אבל אם היינו
מטילים את H על מרחב Krylov החדש שלנו K2, היינו עושים את זה באמצעות מטריצה V
שיש לה וקטור Krylov לכל עמודה ואת הצמוד ההרמיטי שלה שיש לו וקטורי Krylov לשורות. ואז היינו
מקבלים את המטריצה הזו.
למטריצה הזו טכנית יש ממד נמוך יותר מהמקורית שלנו. ברור שההקטנה הזו לא שימושית בסקאלה
הזו. השיטה הזו מיועדת להקטנת מטריצות עם אלפים רבים או אפילו מיליוני שורות ועמודות
לכמות קטנה. אז למה שיטות Krylov שימושיות? מסתבר שהמרשם הפשוט הזה
של פעולת אופרטור הוא לעיתים קרובות הדרך היעילה ביותר להתקרב למצב הערך הנמוך ביותר או מצב היסוד של אופרטור
מטריצה. בואו נהפוך את זה קצת יותר מפורש אם כי נשאיר הוכחה מלאה לטקסט הנלווה. אנחנו רוצים
לפתור בעיה מהצורה h פועל על הוקטור x נותן לנו קבוע כלשהו כפול הוקטור x. בואו נתחיל עם
ניחוש של הוקטור העצמי שלנו x0. זה רק פתרון מקורב. יש לו שגיאה שאנחנו קוראים לה e0. עכשיו אנחנו רוצים
לעשות עדכון של הניחוש הזה שנקרא לו x1 שאנחנו מקווים שישפר את הקירוב שלנו. אפשר לבטא את זה בתור
ה-x0 המקורי פלוס תיקון כלשהו p0 שעדיין צריך להיקבע. אפשר
לחזור על התהליך הזה באופן איטרטיבי ולהוסיף עוד ועוד וקטורי תיקון pi.
ברור שאנחנו רוצים שהשגיאה תקטן אבל זה לא רק המצב שמעניין אותנו. אנחנו גם מעוניינים בפעולה
של h על המצב הזה. אז הגודל שאנחנו באמת רוצים למזער הוא הנורמת-H של השגיאה הזו או הנורמה של
פעולת h על השגיאה הזו.
עכשיו אפשר לראות שזה ביטוי שמערב את p0 ואפשר לשאול את עצמנו אילו בחירות של p ממזערות
את נורמת-H של השגיאה הכי ביעילות. מאיזה מרחב צריך לבחור את התיקון? בתנאים
מסוימים כמו כש-h סימטרית וחיובית מוגדרת, בחירת r התיקונים הראשונים מתוך kr מתבררת
כאופטימלית. במילים פשוטות יותר, אנחנו צריכים דרך כלשהי להכין תת-מרחב טוב שעליו נוכל
להטיל את ההמילטוניאן שלנו. ובמקרים רבים, תת-מרחב Krylov הוא המרחב הנפרס על ידי וקטורי התיקונים היעילים
ביותר לניחוש ההתחלתי שלנו.
להוכחה אמיתית, ראו את הטקסט הנלווה לסרטון הזה.
כל מה שתיארנו עד כה אפשר לעשות באופן קלאסי. אז, איך ומתי נשתמש במחשב קוונטי?
עבור מטריצות גדולות מאוד, שיטת Krylov יכולה לדרוש זמני חישוב ארוכים וכמויות גדולות של זיכרון. הזמן
הנדרש לפעולת מטריצה של H על V מסקייל כמו N בריבוע במקרה הגרוע ביותר.
וזה נעשה עבור כל וקטור שאנחנו רוצים בתת-המרחב שלנו. ממד תת-המרחב R הוא בדרך כלל לא חלק משמעותי
מ-N ולעיתים קרובות מסקייל כמו לוג של N. אז יצירת כל הוקטורים מסקיילת
כמו סדר N^2 log N.
למרות שיש צעדים אחרים כמו אורתוגונליזציה, זה הסקיילינג הדומיננטי שכדאי לזכור.
מחשוב קוונטי מאפשר לנו לשנות אילו תכונות של הבעיה קובעות את הסקיילינג של הזמן והמשאבים
הנדרשים. במקום תלות בגודל המטריצה n לכל אורך הדרך, נראה דברים כמו מספר השוטים ומספר
מחרוזות Pauli הלא-קומוטטיביות שמרכיבות המילטוניאן.
בואו נחקור איך זה עובד.
נזכור שהאופרטור שמפתח בזמן מצב קוונטי הוא האקספוננט של iH חלקי h bar. וזה
מאוד נפוץ, במיוחד במחשוב קוונטי, להוריד את h bar מהסימון.
דרך אחת להבין ואפילו לממש פונקציה אקספוננציאלית כזו של אופרטור היא להסתכל על פיתוח טור
הפורייה שלה. שימו לב שהפעולה הזו על וקטור התחלתי V כלשהו נותנת סכום של איברים
עם חזקות עולות של H שמופעלות על המצב ההתחלתי. נראה שאפשר פשוט ליצור את תת-מרחב Krylov שלנו על ידי פיתוח
בזמן של מצב הניחוש ההתחלתי שלנו. וזה כמעט נכון. האזהרה היא
במימוש הפיתוח בזמן על מחשב קוונטי אמיתי. הרבה מהאיברים בהמילטוניאן לא יהיו קומוטטיביים
אחד עם השני. אז בעוד שכמה אופרטורים אקספוננציאליים פשוטים כמו e בחזקת מינוס i z מתאימים למעגלים
פשוטים המילטוניאנים כלליים לא ומכיוון שהם מכילים איברים לא-קומוטטיביים
אי אפשר פשוט לפרק את האקספוננט למכפלה של אקספוננטים פשוטים כמו שאפשר עם מספרים. אז
זה לא טריוויאלי אבל זה תהליך שנחקר היטב במחשוב קוונטי. אנחנו מבצעים פיתוח בזמן
על מחשבים קוונטיים באמצעות תהליך שנקרא טרוטריזציה שכשלעצמו הוא נושא עשיר. אבל ברמה גבוהה מאוד
על ידי שבירת הפיתוח בזמן לצעדים קטנים נגיד M צעדים אנחנו מגבילים את ההשפעות של האי-קומוטטיביות של
האיברים. בואו נקרא לתת-מרחב Krylov מסדר r שיצרנו בהקשר הקלאסי באמצעות חזקות של h
ישירות תת-מרחב Krylov החזקתי kpr.
עכשיו אנחנו יוצרים מרחב דומה באמצעות אופרטור הפיתוח בזמן היוניטרי u שניתן על ידי האקספוננט של iHt.
נתייחס לזה כמרחב Krylov היוניטרי kur.
תת-מרחב Krylov החזקתי kpr שאנחנו משתמשים בו באופן קלאסי לא ניתן ליצירה ישירה על מחשב קוונטי כי h
הוא לא אופרטור יוניטרי. שימוש בתת-מרחב Krylov היוניטרי ניתן להוכחה כנותן ערבויות התכנסות דומות
לתת-מרחב Krylov החזקתי.
באופן ספציפי, שגיאת מצב היסוד מתכנסת ביעילות כל עוד למצב ההתחלתי V יש חפיפה עם מצב
היסוד האמיתי שלא דועכת אקספוננציאלית וכל עוד יש פער מספיק בין ערכים
עצמיים. כאן חזקות של u הופכות לצעדי זמן שונים. החזקה ה-k של u היא צעד
קדימה בזמן k כפול dt.
אפשר לסמן את האיבר בתת-המרחב שפותח בזמן לסך הכל kdt כ-s תחתית k. אפשר להטיל את
ההמילטוניאן H על תת-מרחב Krylov היוניטרי kur. במילים אחרות, אנחנו
מחשבים כל אלמנט מטריצה של h בבסיס kur. נתייחס למטריצה
המוטלת הזו כ-H טילדה. אלמנטי המטריצה של H טילדה ניתנים על ידי ערכי הציפייה האלה שאפשר
לאמוד באמצעות המחשב הקוונטי.
שימו לב ש-H אפשר לכתוב כסכום של אופרטורי Pauli על qubit-ים שונים ושלא כל אופרטורי Pauli
ניתנים למדידה בו-זמנית. אפשר למיין את איברי Pauli לקבוצות של איברים קומוטטיביים ולמדוד את כולם
בבת אחת. אבל ייתכן שנצטרך הרבה קבוצות כאלה כדי לכסות את כל האיברים. אז מספר קבוצות הקומוטטיביות הנפרדות שאליהן
אפשר לחלק את האיברים ngcp הופך לחשוב. אם אנחנו משתמשים בתת-מרחב Krylov יוניטרי בממד r המטריצה
המתקבלת תהיה בממדים r כפול r. אם r הרבה יותר קטן מ-n אז עשינו
התקדמות שימושית ובדרך כלל r הרבה יותר קטן מ-100 מה שאומר שאפשר ללכסן את זה בקלות על מחשב
קלאסי. אבל נזכור ש-s n ו-s m לא יהיו בדרך כלל אורתוגונליים. לפעמים
אפשר ללכסן מטריצה בבסיס לא-אורתוגונלי. אבל יש סיבות נומריות ופיזיקליות
לעבור קודם לבסיס אורתוגונלי. לכן אנחנו פותרים בעיית ערך עצמי מוכללת באמצעות מטריצת גרם s.
האלמנט ה-mn של מטריצת גרם ניתן על ידי המכפלה הפנימית של s m ב-s n.
גם האלמנטים של H טילדה וגם S מחושבים באמצעות מבחן Hadamard.
בעיית הערך העצמי המוכללת אז הופכת לזה.
כפי שצוין למעלה, ממד תת-מרחב Krylov היוניטרי R קטן באופן אקספוננציאלי מממד
המטריצה ההתחלתית שלנו N. אז בעיית הערך הזו פשוטה לפתרון באופן קלאסי.
לסיכום, אנחנו מתחילים עם מצב ייחוס, ואז מפתחים אותו לתקופות זמן שונות כדי ליצור את תת-מרחב
Krylov היוניטרי. מטילים את ההמילטוניאן על תת-המרחב הזה וגם אומדים את החפיפות של
וקטורי תת-המרחב. לבסוף, פותרים את בעיית הערך המוכללת בממד נמוך באופן קלאסי. בואו נשווה מה
קובע את עלויות החישוב של שימוש בטכניקת Krylov באופן קלאסי ובאופן קוונטי-מכני. כבר שרטטנו את זה
עבור הגרסה הקלאסית ואין אנלוגיות מושלמות בין גישות קלאסיות וקוונטיות לכל הצעדים. אבל הטבלה הזו אוספת כמה
סקיילינגים של צעדים שונים לשיקול. נזכור שלהמילטוניאנים בדרך כלל יש איברים שלא ניתנים למדידה בו-זמנית כי הם
לא קומוטטיביים. אנחנו ממיינים איברים בהמילטוניאן לקבוצות של אופרטורי Pauli קומוטטיביים שאפשר למדוד בו-זמנית ואולי נצטרך הרבה
קבוצות כאלה כדי לתת מענה לכל האיברים שלא קומוטטיביים. כדי לבנות את H טילדה על מחשב קוונטי צריך
מדידות נפרדות לכל קבוצה של מחרוזות Pauli קומוטטיביות בהמילטוניאן. וכל אחת מהן דורשת הרבה שוטים. צריך לעשות את זה עבור R
בריבוע אלמנטי מטריצה שונים שמתאימים ל-R בריבוע שילובים של גורמי פיתוח בזמן שונים. לפעמים
יש דרכים להקטין את זה. אבל בטיפול הגס הזה, הזמן הנדרש לזה מסקייל בערך כמו
מספר השוטים כפול מספר קבוצות איברי Pauli הקומוטטיביים כפול r בריבוע.
צריך לאמוד את האלמנטים של s מה שמסקייל כמו מספר השוטים
כפול r בשלישית. אנחנו רואים שדיאגונליזציה קוונטית של Krylov יכולה להיות שימושית במקרים שבהם מספר קבוצות Pauli הקומוטטיביות
בהמילטוניאן הוא יחסית קטן.
תלות הסקיילינג הזו מרמזת על כמה יישומים שבהם שיטת Krylov יכולה להיות שימושית ואחרים שבהם כנראה
שלא. לכמה המילטוניאנים יש מורכבות גבוהה כשהם ממופים ל-qubit-ים הכוללים מחרוזות Pauli רבות שאינן קומוטטיביות
שלא ניתנות בקלות לחלוקה לכמה קבוצות קומוטטיביות.
זה לעיתים קרובות נכון לגבי בעיות כימיה קוונטית. לדוגמה, מורכבות זו מציבה שני אתגרים עיקריים עבור
מחשבים קוונטיים של הטווח הקרוב. ראשית, אמידת כל אלמנט של H טילדה הופכת ליקרה חישובית בגלל
מספר האיברים הרב. שנית, מעגלי הטרוטר הנדרשים הופכים לעמוקים מדי. שתי הנקודות האלה
יהיו פחות בעייתיות כשמחשבים קוונטיים יגיעו לסבילות לתקלות, אבל צריך להתחשב בהן בטווח הקרוב. אפילו מערכות עם מיפויים פשוטים יותר
מאלה שבכימיה קוונטית עלולות לחוות את אותם מכשולים אם להמילטוניאנים יש יותר מדי איברים לא-קומוטטיביים.
שיטת Krylov הכי שימושית כשאפשר לחלק את ההמילטוניאן למספר קטן יחסית של קבוצות Pauli קומוטטיביות
וכש-H קל ליישום במעגלי טרוטר. שני התנאים האלה מתקיימים. לדוגמה,
עבור הרבה מודלי רשת שמעניינים בפיזיקה, KQD שימושי במיוחד אם מאוד מעט ידוע על מצב
היסוד. זה נובע מערבויות ההתכנסות המובנות שלו ומהישימות שלו בתרחישים שבהם
שיטות חלופיות לא אפשריות בגלל ידע לא מספיק על מצב היסוד.
בעוד ש-KQD הוא כלי חזק, ההיבטים הגוזלים זמן של הפרוטוקול, במיוחד אמידת כל
אלמנט של ההמילטוניאן המוטל והחפיפה של מצבי Krylov, מהווים הזדמנויות לשיפור.
גישה חלופית כוללת קירוב מצב Krylov באמצעות מעגלי טרוטר, ואז דגימת
המצב המקורב כדי לקבל הטלה על הבסיס החישובי ואז הטלת h על תת-המרחב
הנפרס על ידי מצבי הבסיס החישובי האלה.
במקרים שבהם זה ישים, המתודולוגיה הזו הידועה כדיאגונליזציה קוונטית של Krylov מבוססת דגימה SKQD
עשויה להציע הפחתות משמעותיות בדרישות הזמן והמשאבים בהשוואה ל-KQD המסורתי.
השילוב של טכניקות תת-מרחב Krylov עם שיטות דגימה ב-SKQD מייצג חזית מרגשת
באלגוריתמים קוונטיים.